live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsay show where we help you get
control of your money get ahead in your
career and get on the path to living
well i'm george campbell joined today by
my good friend ken coleman and we are
excited to take your call about life
money career toxic bosses you name it we
are here to help the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five now if you noticed
there in the intro ken you heard
something a little different didn't you
yeah we got a new studio broadcasting
from the pods moving in storage studio
we are super excited to pump and pump to
partner with those folks good people
over at pods moving and storage if you
don't know
um they are the industry leader in this
space and a lot of people are moving out
there 23 million people moving each year
in the u.s and one in five ramsey
listeners told us they plan to move the
next year wow and pods has been trusted
with six million moves now and we're
always looking to partner with trusted
companies and their leadership team's
incredible we've been working with them
for months and months and months
and uh they uh we have the honor of
having now the pods moving in storage
studio so make sure you check them out
if you are in the uh in that space where
you're going all right i'm making a move
this year we know there's been a big
migration a lot of californians have
moved to tennessee and all over the
place yeah and uh moving can be a
difficult thing and pods makes it easy i
love the flexibility you have having the
pods container right there as long as
you need it yeah i i feel like i'm gonna
give a little extra a little free uh
advice today to start the show isn't it
all free it is thank you for pointing
that out george uh i i'm gonna give some
moving advice uh that is in addition to
our good friends at potts um if you were
one of the 23 million people
uh don't ask your friends for help oh i
feel like there's a boundary here
where like i think in college is the
last time you can ask a friend to help
you move once you're a grown adult don't
ask your friends don't promise pizza
beer whatever your your don't do it
don't ask your friends for help
they don't want to help
some will say
yes because they don't know how to say
no
others like me will make up an excuse uh
as to why i can't help you so just just
avoid the tension all together ken would
fake a root canal just to get out of
helping you move i wouldn't put it past
me well the reason i don't work out and
the only reason is that no one asks me
to move when i'm just a little thank you
oh that's your reason for not working
out i even have offered and they go they
look at me up and down they go no i'm
good i'm good true story last time i
asked friends to help stacey and i move
uh it was in the atlanta area and one of
my friends showed up true story with one
of those old-school leather weight belts
to support his back like that was gonna
help you gotta watch out for your back
these days ken you gotta protect the
back you're the kind of guy that i would
call if i needed like a gluten-free
snack and a latte as i was moving james
is on it james is snapping back already
he's right though we don't call you to
help with the couch
the cushion's bigger than we haven't
gone to us we call you for snacks not a
single call has been taken and it's
already become the roast of george
campbell guys we love you george this is
a true friday show let's help greg out
all right greg joins us up first in fort
collins colorado greg welcome to the
show
hello fellas thank you very much for
taking the call it's an honor to speak
with you guys today we're honored to
take the call how's it going
oh not too bad i've been a long time
listener my
myself my new wife been married uh since
february and
i converted her over to the dave ramsey
plan i've been uh
on the program uh
ten plus years
on date we're both on baby step three
saving our uh our uh
uh
down payment for uh i'm sorry our
emergency fund next up the down payment
for a house but i'm calling today
because
i came in with a little bit of baggage
of
essentially i had over 27 lines of
credit that uh thanks to you guys over
the past couple years i've paid
everything off
there's no open accounts i go on my
credit uh report all of my lines of
credit are closed
but i went from having an excellent
credit score to it's been slowly
trickling down one or two points
per month uh over to pat the last line
of credit was closed in 2020
um and when i called both transunion and
equifax today and you know used the
ramsey curse word they act as though
this
policy of paying off your your uh
your debts and closing your accounts
they're
essentially
my credit score is
not even going to go to zero and what
they're telling me is
the only way that it goes to zero is if
there are negative reports on uh on your
account so i don't have any derogatory
pain or issues all of my payments were
uh paid off in full and i guess um i
mean i'm we're almost at the point if
i'm about to make a contradiction start
opening up lines of credit no that's to
get my
just to be able to afford it or not be
able to afford but be able to apply for
a uh for a loan so i guess my question
is
what do i do when i went from an 850 or
i'm sorry a high 800 credit score to
sitting at 600 and you're telling me
that my credit score isn't going to
disappear
well they're in the business of keeping
you in debt number one so not the most
trustworthy folks to ask about your
credit score um now when you say going
to zero that is true your credit score
will not go to zero i mean when you look
at the fico score the lowest you could
go is 300. and when we say we want a
zero credit score what we really mean is
we want it to disappear we want it to
become indeterminable so no i don't
think your credit score is going to go
from 600 to 500 to 300 and then maybe
hopefully go away what will happen how
long have you uh what's the last account
that was closed how long ago was that
uh like july 2020
that was the final you closed that line
all payments were made
correct okay and you've contacted every
single
one of the lenders the trade lines you
had opened and said hey i want to verify
that these accounts are closed
yeah um uh transunion equifax also
clarified that everything was closed on
their end so
i haven't seen any uh any any debt
collector showing up at my door so
that's the confusing part well i mean
for sure you're debt-free i'm not saying
that you still have open debts sitting
out there
but normally it takes about six to
eighteen months for that credit score to
become indeterminable so that if you
pulled you tried to pull your credit
score it would say no history found
and so i don't know if it's just because
you had so many lines of credit that it
could be taking longer but you're saying
july 2020 so we're sitting here at uh
two years now and you're saying it still
hasn't disappeared
correct and those were student loans a
house uh car
a handful of credit cards yeah so all of
my lines of credit everything is
the the car and the student i'm sorry
the car and the house were the last two
things and everything was closed off in
like 2018. so there were no there
weren't even any credit cards open at
that point so you're saying the last
thing you the very last thing you closed
was july 2020 and since then there's
been no open lines
well i mean you can i would i would keep
going with the baby steps save the
emergency fund it's going to take a
while to save up that that down payment
and i can't imagine that it could be
much longer until the score just drops
off and so i would continue checking
every few months with those credit
bureaus to see if that drops off you can
contact churchill mortgage and ask them
what this process looks like when you
are ready and say hey what is what do i
need to do in order to do manual
underwriting because that's your true
question right you want to get into a
home without a credit score right
well i can tell you for sure it can be
done i've done it myself and it didn't
kill me i'm here to tell the tale that i
survived ken and i'm proud to say it so
stay the course i wish i could help you
figure out what's going on with all
these credit lines but pull all your
credit reports and you double check them
to make sure they're all officially
closed zero balances everything and
hopefully within six months you're
continuing on the baby steps and we have
an indeterminable credit score check out
episode seven of the fine print where we
talk about the dirty truth behind your
credit score if you want more info on
that appreciate the call this is the
ramsay show thank you
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined today by ken coleman host
of the aptly named ken coleman show and
we are taking your calls about life
money career you name it the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five andy joins us up next in
wyoming andy welcome to the ramsay show
hi dude how you doing gentlemen doing
great how can we help
um yes sir
i
found dave's program
about
four or five months ago and
i'm considering popping the question and
asking my girlfriend to marry me and
i just want to know
more or less your teachings or your
thoughts on when a prenup is appropriate
what made you consider that as part of
this
um well i
currently currently do pretty well
looking at what dave says how you
configure your networks i'm
pretty much
almost there at
a millionaire
and my girlfriend um she
i think she's just a little concerned
when we get married uh
that
she doesn't want to feel like she's
mooching off me so i'm going to be
bringing a little bit more to the table
financially like when we purchase a
house together
and um
so
so
let me ask you a question uh
did she bring up the idea of the prenup
or she was sharing maybe some of her
insecurities
because she's not bringing much income
to the marriage and then you thought
well maybe if i do a prenup she'll feel
better i want to know more about who's
whose idea was behind this question
um i think it was kind of us both um
when i found dave's thing i had a little
bit of debt and i got it paid off but
i'm
kind of on a weird spot because i was
already in baby step 7
and i had
my houses paid for what i have in
retirement
is
is almost close to a million plus i got
about 80 000
in the bank and after i paid off my debt
which was about 10 000 um you know i
make about
120 a year
and she makes pretty good income because
she's a nurse what does she mean
uh i think right now she's almost close
to a hundred how much do you worry about
her marrying you and then divorcing you
to take half of your income
um well
i know most of my money is more or less
in real estate
um
my daddy left me a house when he passed
so
um i make a pretty good living i i
got about
no no i asked you i asked you how much
do you think about or worry about
this woman who's your current girlfriend
who you're thinking about popping the
question to
how much do you worry about her marrying
you to then take half of your assets
i really don't think about a lot
um i guess there's just that always what
if factor um we've only been dating
about six months
but known each other for about 10 years
so well do you do you find her to be a
trustworthy person
you've known her for 10 years
i do so she's known you before you had
any money really
yeah and and she was previously married
before for a few years and when they got
divorced um
you know she didn't she didn't take
anything as weird as it sounds i think
the fact that she brought up a prenup
because she's insecure about how much
money you have versus what she's
bringing to their marriage
george it doesn't feel like a person
who's gonna try to take you
uh i just don't think you need one in
this situation no we usually say if you
have substantial assets and we're
talking you have a giant you make a
million dollars or you have two million
dollars worth of assets or more and all
of a sudden she shows up in the picture
and i'm not seeing that with this i mean
you guys have about the same income uh
yes you do you are further ahead
financially but i don't see this as a
scenario where i'm worried about this so
i would continue on without one and um
i think you're going to be just fine she
doesn't see and you said in this
previous marriage when she was divorced
there wasn't this angle of i'm gonna try
to get as much as i can out of this
no sir no she doesn't get any child
support or any other financial help from
her ex-husband especially because they
have two kids together you've known her
for 10 years you can't hide crazy for a
decade no no sir i don't believe she's
crazy i just think i
i guess i'm just trying to do
the right thing to make sure she's
comfortable we'll make her comfortable
another way i i think this is a this is
a cry
for validation that's what i think and i
think you got to validate and there
could be some baggage from a previous
divorce that's right that she's carrying
through this and so what i would say is
you don't need a prenup but i would
pause and take this slow and you know
you've been officially together now for
six months so do take some right steps
go through financial peace university do
some pre-marital counseling have some
hard conversations so that you're both
confident going into this and whether or
not you can get her to reveal it to you
or not but even through a professional
counselor george is right what is it the
root the question that you need to help
her answer
is what is at the root of this
insecurity this financial insecurity and
comparing our incomes or our savings
there's a root there's something deeper
it's manifesting itself in this
conversation this way but it's a much
deeper issue get to the source of that
get some healing around that source and
i think everything's going to be awesome
thanks for the call appreciate it jason
joins us up next in dc jason welcome to
the show
hey guys how are you how are you we are
doing great how can we help today
uh well basically i need some get some
guidance and some
some reassurance that everything will be
okay uh i'm i'm about 60 000 in debt uh
i'm married i'm uh we'll have a wife and
soon to be two kids
our next one's due this weekend congrats
and uh
well thanks and
basically we're living paycheck to
paycheck i'm the only one working
because my wife basically stayed home to
the kids because
kind of being cheaper that way
and but um
i'm not sure how to
navigate this how much money jason let's
simplify this because you sound really
scared my man yeah and i want you to
know first of all everything's going to
be all right that's what i first want
you to hear so i literally want you to
take a deep breath right now
all right
i mean literally you're gonna be okay
now
how much money let's simplify this how
much money let's give me a real number
would make a difference between you
being paycheck to paycheck and would
give you a sense of okay
i can dig out of the 60 but i'm not
going to be stressed out of my mind in
digging out what would be a number if we
could give more income right now that
would make a a real difference how much
more money
uh probably
double what i'm making now give me a
number i need a number
about a hundred thousand you're making a
hundred thousand and you you need a
hundred thousand more you make fifty oh
no um oh i mix i make a thousand a week
before taxes okay okay that's what i'm
looking at all right so what i'm trying
to do is i'm trying to simplify this
because it's really scary right now
isn't it yeah okay so here's the deal
you're making a thousand a week is that
gross or net
that's gross that's your gross okay so
here's my point if you brought in an
additional fifteen hundred to two
thousand dollars that would make an
enormous difference every month wouldn't
it
yes
my friend
right now in this economy
and you're in in the dc area
there are so many part-time jobs
that you can do you're going to be tired
but at least mom is going to be home
with the babies
but right now you could get easily 20
hours a week and making 20 an hour
and you just start running the numbers
on that but right now the quickest way
for you to get some relief is more
income while you're working the baby
steps the baby steps are going to work
but what you need for relief is more
money coming in so if that's walmart
target you're stocking shelves whatever
you go find you a good
20 hour 25 hour a week part-time job
paying you 18 20 22 an hour and those
are there i talk about it every day on
the ken coleman show and that's going to
make the difference you feel me
yeah i hear you
can you do it
yeah i can do it now
you better do it yeah
well i do uh i drive for like food
delivery services out to work sometimes
that's not enough money it's not enough
money i know my friend go get you a job
where you're gonna have to drive all
over the place and put wear and tear on
your car go get you a 20 an hour job one
of those big retailers or whatever doing
anything you can
listen more income is the play right now
and it's out there the best job economy
we've ever seen
the august jobs report just showed it go
get some more money by working longer
hours jason hang on the line i'm going
to gift you financial peace university
watch lessons one and two it's gonna
help you get a kickstart on budgeting
and getting out of this mess man we're
hoping for you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by ken
coleman this is the ramsey show
if you've been watching the news or been
on the car lot lately you know that car
prices have been insane and with that
comes some insane decisions
and then with that becomes a new average
monthly car payment of
733 dollars according to kelly blue book
wow can that is insane wow
that's the average that's the average
wow and interest rates of course rising
so the average you know car loan
interest rates really tight georgia
four percent
so my chest is too much
because cars are getting more expensive
of course the car payment goes up
because that car that you would use to
pay 35 for is now 45 or 50.
and so here's a another i don't want to
give you a heart attack on air can but
the average price paid for a new vehicle
is up to a new record of 48 000
wow
that is nuts
and so we like to react to some videos
here and so the producer sent us this
one uh that makes this number look low
you ready i'm gonna about take your
breath away is that right yeah you ready
for that better
ken has not seen this video i've not
seen this this is not method acting this
is true we're gonna get ken's true
reaction roll that beautiful bean
footage
sir what is your car payment
uh mine is 13.25 and what kind of
vehicle is that it's a 22 ford raptor
okay you have another payment i do
actually my wife's is a thousand
it's a 22 ford expedition
hey ma'am
what is 2300 cars
13.86 and what kind of car requires a
1386 payment a 2022 grand wagoneer
series 3.
hey sir what is your car payment
i got a couple of them but uh
first one's
14.45 what kind of car is that that's a
new gmc sierra 2500 denali
what's the airline uh it's a wide body
cts v that's 1161. i don't even know
what that is
wide body something oh
okay wow so here's what we just
witnessed for those of you listening on
radio
those people work at a car dealership
yeah and that's their real numbers okay
i was going to ask you where they're
from because they did you see the gal
that struck out to me stuck out to me
when she said he said it was the setup
and she literally went
like
it like just laughed it off
like it's uh
you know like uncle larry and his gout
and we hear about every thanksgiving you
know it's like well here here it comes i
gotta go to thanksgiving at the
coleman's yeah well i don't actually
have an uncle larry and and gals nothing
to joke about but it's true
but but then she was just so like well
this is what it is right i mean it's
like you're so cavalier about it oh yeah
here it comes like she knew the video
was coming she was like all right here's
your 1386 dollar carbon i got to tell
you i have heartburn and i haven't had
anything to eat today i need a tums
right now there's some in the in the
studio bathroom right now okay i'll use
those during the so let's recap what
just happened these are folks that work
at a car dealership revealing how much
their car payment is and of course if
you work at a car dealership you get the
latest and greatest
and so all of those were brand new 22
raptor 1325 a month we got the gmc the
denali's
1445 and
it hurt my brain ken it hurt my heart
more than my brain yeah one the first
couple when he talked about his wife's
car with his 2 300 a month in car
payments and this is and what's crazy
about this is that nobody thinks about
this this payment as going towards a
asset that is devaluing that's right
every mile you drive it it's losing
value it's not like a house
well and we we've got stats on this ken
we know that the average car depreciates
at an insane rate i mean we're talking
about 40 50 60 depreciation after five
years oh boy so let's walk through
depreciation and then i'll do some other
math that will make you never want a car
payment again so the minute you drive
the car off the lot already nine to
eleven percent negotiation so let's say
you get a car for 35 grand one minute
later it's worth 31.5 dude i would
literally be the guy with that in my
back of my head i would be exiting the
car dealer parking lot and i would just
be like stuck i i couldn't press the gas
anymore they're like sir we need you to
leave the lot i'm like it's going to
drop
imagine just having four grand in your
pocket and throwing it out the window
when you leave the car alive
and that's not even with your interest
rate so you are paying interest
on a depreciating asset so one year
later the 35 grand car now worth 28. two
years 24. three years 21. four years 18.
five years later the 35 grand car is
worth fifteen thousand dollars
this on average
so i did some math can as you know i
like to do
and if you invest that payment let's say
you got a reasonable car that was maybe
ten thousand dollars instead of forty
eight thousand dollars
and you instead invested that 1400 bucks
with compound growth let's say at a 10
rate of return over 20 years that 1400
com that's monthly so we're talking 168
a year
that turns into almost a million dollars
how do you like the car friends that's
your that car after 20 years ain't worth
nothing
you could have had a million bucks now
if it was 30 years you would have 2.7
million dollars
does that not make you go
maybe this is a bad financial decision
yeah okay but that makes too much sense
george you're right i'm sorry ken uh i
kind of my buddy's got the denali and so
i got to get the dually to impress this
is the deal so we think that we deserve
to drive a nice car that's the first
problem this is this is inherently human
stuff i'm serious about it's like you
can't make sense with numbers because
that that doesn't that doesn't uh help
us with our humanness because our
humanness goes well look god have a car
and if i haven't gotta have a car
safe and reliable and everybody's got a
new car and if i get the new car it's
got a warranty on it so i'll take it
down to the old gmc and get it fixed
it's all this reasoning and we kind of
talk ourselves into this narrative that
goes
yeah i don't want to hear that
okay that's great george but i gotta
have a car
and this isn't this is really the
problem
that's the root of it and a lot of it is
comparisons if we're going to be honest
and you want to have a facade that
you're successful you're doing well new
car
same
never done it
um and you know i like old cars you're
an old soul but let me give you another
little thing here all right so i i've
driven older cars you know just like
just late you know just normal stuff but
then i recently had the opportunity to
get a a a
volkswagen convertible carmen gea that
is worth about 24 grand
easy 24 grand that's big time it's 48
years old no it's 50 some years old
right that's older than you it is just
barely thank you george what are you
saying i'm an antique
you could be if you were a car get my
point is like if you're gonna if you
like if you're gonna buy something if
you want a car then get something
classic that actually has some value but
all these new fancy cars
aren't worth crap
two years later you want to trade it and
get a new one
and a lot of this ken i'm gonna throw
the guys under the bus here because
men are susceptible to this uh the
trucks truck guys are a certain breed
and you know dave ramsey's a truck guy
himself and of course he has a risk
he's not making payments he's not paying
interest no but there's something about
truck guys and wanting to impress the
other truck guys yeah my truck's bigger
than your truck there it is and dave
always use the joke if your truck
payment is bigger than your mortgage
payment you might be a redneck
oh listen i was listening to that uh
comedy roundup channel on siriusxm
because our show is on siriusxm
and uh i
it was jeff foxworthy and he said uh
if
if you
uh are making out in the back of a truck
that is being towed to the repo you
might be horrendous that's brilliant
you know and that's your problem that's
quite the visual yeah i know well i
cleaned it up a little bit it's just one
of the things causing america to be
broke because you add that with the
student loan crisis
and living off of credit cards because
you need the rewards and the airline
miles that's right then you tack on the
giant mortgage payment yeah because you
wanted to get into a home because you
were throwing money away on rent yeah
now we're talking thousands and
thousands of dollars going to lenders so
they can have big buildings downtown
while you remain broke forever so i want
to set some people free george please
nobody cares how big your truck is
nobody cares louder for the guys in the
back nobody cares how big your truck is
nobody cares how nice your truck is
nobody cares how nice your car is nobody
cares how old your car is nobody cares
if your car backfires when it pulls into
the parking lot like at the end of the
day everybody else has got their own you
know what going on in their life and
they're trying to deal with it they
don't care so why do you care what they
might think i got news for you
they don't care pastor ken just dropped
a sermon right there folks and if you're
embarrassed by your car guess what
there's always spaces in the back
so here's the deal not caring what other
people think is a superpower and when
you gain that you can gain financial
freedom that's what we're here for
that's rich
boom this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined by ken coleman we're
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five
five two two five right now folks you're
hearing a lot of talking heads in the
news stirring up fear about the real
estate market
and here's the deal if you believe them
you think the housing market's gonna
crash it's going to be a repeat of the
2008 housing crisis but you're not
hearing the truth
and you can't make decisions based on
fear you need the facts and here they
are in 2008 there was a huge supply of
homes but not enough buyer demand so
home prices dropped that's not what's
happening in today's market right now
there are half as many homes for sale
and twice as many buyers
that means home prices aren't going down
anytime soon they're growing at a slower
rate we're seeing these over inflated
asking prices come back down to reality
so if you're ready to buy or sell a home
you don't need to wait any longer you
can still win in this market but you've
got to work with a pro an experienced
real estate agent and we've done the
hard work for you vetting agents who
know your local market and have the
transactions to back it up so if you
want to connect with a ramsey trusted
agent for free go to ramseysolutions.com
agent and check out our endorsed local
providers program again that's
ramseysolutions.com
agent
well ken i see that the team has got you
some tums well uh our last segment you
were breaking down the fact that the
average car payment now in america has
grown to 733
a month and then you showed me a clip of
people that have over 2 000 a month in
car payments and so i made a joke about
tums and then
there they are here they are and so that
gave me a little bit of heartburn i'm
going to try a couple here you know
these are different colors ken might
choke there we go we're going to witness
this oh we got it which one do you think
i'm going to do two i think the orange
is the best orange and the green one's
gross to me we can all agree on that
right
yeah they're very fruity so i gave ken
heartburn talking about these are not
your granddaddy's tums please keep
chewing into the mic ken let's just run
this thing into the ground and have
james take us james take us off the air
we love it we're here for it these are
the tropical flavors oh good assorted
fruit it says
i'm glad that the team sprung for the
tropical flavor i feel much better but
i'm gonna tell you something
you ought to be grabbing for the tums
too if you have over a thousand dollars
a month hundred dollars a month in car
payments that kind of heartburn you're
gonna need a stronger antacid than that
i'm gonna need a swig of water
well let's go to the phones it's a free
call triple eight eight two five five
two two five caleb joins us in
cincinnati caleb welcome to the ramsay
show
god bless you gentlemen how y'all doing
good what's your car payment
550. there we go all right
you're below average what are we
celebrating this now i'm so confused how
can we help today
well my main question i own 19 000 left
on my car it's my one transportation to
work
um
do i just take this punch and just get
it paid off and never make this mistake
again
should i look to refinance should i look
to get get it off my hands how much does
it work
um
they say at the auction is a lot less
it's it's a 2019 toyota corolla how many
miles
um 80 000.
what's the kelly blue book on that
i honestly don't know you need to know
there's some homework you got to do and
check for private sale we're not going
to take this thing to auction if you
want to get the best bang for your buck
this it's going to be through a private
sale
you can also check sites like carvana
and vroom and those kinds of online what
was the year
2019. 2019 toyota corolla 80 000 miles
ken is doing his due diligence here
doing the research for you to be a good
guy well i mean this takes just moments
while he does that help him out george
i'll give you some research what's your
income
uh 32 a month
32 a month is that take-home or is that
gross
um that is
take-home okay
i mean it's a lot of car for your income
it's not outside the bounds we say that
you know we don't want more than 50
percent of your income tied up in things
with motors i've got an update george
all right give us that right this is
carvana a national uh brand and they've
got a uh used uh toyota 2019 toyota
corolla 79 000 miles that's right about
where you're at 21 5.
so i just so that's what they're selling
it for i think that's what they're
selling it for but again if you sell
this privately
and you come in a little bit under what
the car dealers are asking for you can
move this thing and not have to go to
auction that's all i wanted to tell you
it's an option as george walks you
through do you have any money saved how
much do you have in cash
zero don't have anything saved yeah okay
how quickly could you save up a few
thousand dollars
um
you're gonna you're getting side jobs
we're selling other stuff how quickly
could you save up five grand
if if i go back to my second job um i
can make it in a month
okay
could you pay off the car the 19k
if you really hustled
realistically if i really really push
[Music]
a year how much other debt do you have
i have
i
it's like 30 000 total um seven of it is
tied up in student loans
um i i don't know what i'm gonna do with
that um and then the other stuff is like
medical me and my wife got married so my
my silly young butt put rings on there
like i got two thousand dollars with the
rings
the silly stuff is your wife working
outside the home
no we have a nine month old daughter oh
congratulations
thank you well this one's gonna be on
you we're gonna get back to that second
job we're gonna get the income up i'm
okay with you keeping it but i want you
to have a very aggressive goal of how
quickly we're paying it off
what's her car worth does she have one
she does not okay
then that means we're within the
parameters here
my plan was to
stay with this one and pay it off and
save on the side and get her something
you know that is
safe or whatever even if i had to get a
little honda civic that i can take to
work and let her and the baby use this
car i want to get a second vehicle but
i just
every time i hear nineteen thousand and
i mean
have you
tailored
have you done the research on what you
can get for five thousand dollars
um i have um as far as like
um
what does it let go or whatever you know
the facebook marketplace like the
private little sales like that but uh
um is that is that what you would
suggest i am suggesting you research it
i i don't disagree with george i think
that you can go work your tail off and
make some really good money and begin to
pay all of the debt down using our debt
snowball i mean you know the 19 000 i
think is your largest debt
but as it relates to
550 a month i believe you said if that
were to come off of your budget you
would feel in a year you'd have close to
seven grand yeah so i look at things
like that and i go okay if i can quickly
come up with five grand
and then i can sell this car and i can
go get a decent car i mean it's an older
it's going to have higher miles but i
can get a car that's going to get me
from point a to point b
and it knocks out a huge chunk of debt
man i do i have some wind in my sails
i'm always for fast forwarding the
relief and the peace especially when
you've got a newborn yeah you gotta you
need a second car pretty soon so newborn
doesn't care how nice the car is all
right
you know and and quite frankly it
doesn't have to be fancy it just needs
to be
dependable and if it does need
mechanical work something that doesn't
cost you a ton it's it's out there so i
that's what i would be doing because
i could feel the pressure on you right
now and i think if you were to relieve
550 a month it would be massively huge
for you what so caleb how much does the
second job make if you went back to it
uh it's 14 an hour it's part time three
days a week so i make like 250 uh every
week okay so what is a thousand a month
what's that job
fast food
yeah bro i started this fast food when i
was a kid so that's just something safe
and easy to go back to i look into
retail right now
i would too uh even if you got to schlep
some tables i'm telling you man the
opportunity to make 20 bucks an hour or
more right now is right in front of you
okay well i make 20 an hour at my first
job should i look to make more yeah
increasing income and selling stuff will
fast forward this really quickly what's
that job the 20 bucks an hour
i'm a welder oh cool
yeah i mean i know i know we're big and
i know like that there is a very high
ceiling for welding but i'm fresh out of
school and i'm i'm trying to get that
six months on my resume
i'm trying to be patient trying to let
god do his thing good man caleb listen
if i'm you i'm talking to everybody i
know in the welding industry and i'm
looking for side jobs because i think
you getting side jobs as a welder even
though you're young and inexperienced
it's going to pay you better than the 14
an hour fast food thing and more
experience
i'm here for it well we're pushing for
you man you got this and uh the way
you've been talking i think we're
getting rid of this car we're saving up
buying a cheap beater right now and uh
that'll get you debt-free a whole lot
faster and get you to financial peace
that is the goal thanks for the call
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to my co-host ken
coleman all the folks in the booth
austin ben james zack and andrew and you
america we appreciate you listening in
we'll be back with you before you know
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsay show where we help you get
control of your money get ahead in your
career and get on the path to living
well
i'm george campbell joined today by
best-selling author ken coleman and
we're excited to take your call america
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five now if you missed
the last hour of the show you heard that
right pods moving and storage is our new
studio sponsor and we are so proud to
partner with those guys awesome team
awesome company if you're looking for an
affordable option that puts you in
control of your move check them out
eight eight eight eight two
two is the number to call randy's
kicking us off in albuquerque randy
welcome to the show
hi guys thanks for taking my call happy
to take it how's it going with you
oh not too bad i got a conundrum i'm
hoping you can help me with
here in a few weeks i'll be getting laid
off from my job
oh man
about that i don't yeah
it happens i guess
um
i don't have any debt other than the
mortgage
i owe about 163 on the mortgage
um
and i'm not 100 sure about the number
that i'm gonna get in my severance so
i'm guessing it's 75 to 80 000 right and
i have 40 000 saved up
and i have the option of selling a
motorcycle that i could get probably
another 35 out of
so my question is is should i go ahead
and try to pay off the mortgage and be
penniless and jobless
or
try to start up a locksmithing business
and try to continue to make the mortgage
payments and
continue on with life
interesting what what have you been
doing in your work
i work at a power plant okay and they're
shutting the power plant they're
shutting the power plant down
permanently
and what's your what's your trade at the
power plant what's your skill set in
i'm an operator so
a race car driver drives the car which
is what i do
actually i'm a supervisor
uh then you have the the support teams
the mechanics and electricians and that
kind of thing what is your salary in
that job
120 120 and so the locksmith business is
this something you've been kicking
around for a while or is this a
relatively new idea
uh about a year okay and uh how much do
you know about the locksmith business
you talked to some guys know some guys
that are in it
i've been running for about the last six
months i've been running around with the
guy okay good what what's he make
uh
i was actually considering purchasing
his business and
this year i think he's on track for
about 120 in revenue
right but he's not paying himself that
right
oh no
yeah i mean
george there's a there's a money
question here and then there's also the
the the work question and the key is i
don't see it as binary options should
you be penniless and jobless or start a
locksmith business i think there's a
compromise here i do too we hang tight
we find a new job we have a pile of
money and then we move forward i i so
let me speak to the job front uh because
i i think george you and i are on the
same page i don't want him i don't want
him wiping out a savings on this not
when he makes really good money he has
no other debt the 163 we can attack and
we don't know what future income looks
like yeah um so
um
i'd like to see you
use that severance let's say that 75 of
severance that gives you a little bit of
time to make some good decisions
and i would be trying the locksmith
business a little bit on the side
give it give it or give it a run but but
kind of do it on the side
uh if that's even possible um because i
know when people need a locksmith it's
not like you know a 9 to 5 schedule
but i'd like to see you make a
transition into something else
professionally get you closer to the 120
and and give yourself a little bit more
time to explore and and and find out
what needs to be true for me to make 100
120 as a locksmith until you're really
clear on that i wouldn't go all in on
that
okay are you married
i am my wife works uh she just started a
new job this week as a matter of fact uh
how about all that's new information how
much she gonna make
65. all right have you talked to her
about this
oh yeah she's she's on board with it she
doesn't have a problem with it i'm just
i'm at this fork in the road and i just
don't know which way to go well this is
new information so if she's gonna make
65 and you're getting let's just take
the low number you don't know this for
sure
but let's say you get 75 and severance
uh
you guys could probably be comfortable
off the 75 and the 65 together
correct the 75 severance and 65 years
she's gonna make comfortable off of that
okay okay well that changes my advice a
little bit because i i think that now
you've got a chance to go for it
and and see what it does and you've got
no other debt but your house
certainly the the motorcycle does
represent if you want to sell that in
fact they're even asking us if you
should sell it
are you open to selling it is this
emotional is this sentimental to you are
you kind of like i don't use it much
anymore i'm good to get rid of it
yes and no both yes to both of those
i've been riding for a long long time
it's part of part of me that's
my
one of my passions and
but if i need to let it go i'll let it
go i'd hold on to it
based on what i'd hang on for now now if
you get a if if the income isn't there
that's a lot of motorcycle for making 65
a year and so let's wait and see what's
next for you before we sell that you've
got a big pile of cash but i would also
look into leadership and supervisor
roles how many years of experience do
you have with that
uh since 2012.
so we're talking you've got a decade of
experience in leadership and supervising
you're telling me another company
wouldn't hire you in that kind of role
not make the same kind of money i'm
making now right but i think you really
want to be a locksmith am i hearing that
correctly in your voice you really want
to do this
i i really do
yeah but if it doesn't make financial
sense i don't want to you know i want to
be i'd rather be secure than be a
locksmith okay if that's what it takes
right so i don't know if if if you can
if you can do some contract work for
your buddy
you know when he may needs a few extra
hands and you just do it and you kind of
really dive into the industry you know
what he's making but if you had time to
do a little more research and go what
would it take to spit off the amount of
revenue that i need to pay myself
um i think there's still too many
questions to commit to full-time so i'm
with george i
i would look for another position that
maybe even pays you 80 or 90. okay while
we get the locksmith while we figure out
if we're gonna in fact really invest in
this
you don't know what you need to know to
commit right now you just said that and
that's okay
um i'd keep the bike you got 40 thousand
that's a very good if you're itching to
pay off that mortgage and you've got the
pile of cash outside of your emergency
fund and selling the bike can get you
debt free to where you can do
locksmithing and not have to worry man
i'm doing that i'm taking my dream job
over the bike we can get another bike
later so that's my plan and i think it's
uh i think that will lead you to where
you want to go it's things you're
getting laid off but i see a lot of
silver lining here that you get to step
into something you've been wanting to do
and you've gotten to a place financially
where you're able to do it without a ton
of stress and that's why we do these
baby steps it allows us to live more
freely in every other area of our life
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined by ken
coleman host of the ken coleman show you
can find all those shows on the ramsey
network or wherever you listen to
podcasts
we are taking your calls this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i can help answer your money
questions if you're trying to get out of
debt get on a budget maybe save up that
emergency fund start investing
trying to figure out if you should buy
or sell the car the house and ken is
here to help answer those career
questions which right now can there's a
lot of people
wondering about their career wondering
if it's time to switch wondering what to
do because of a layoff yeah just a lot
of movement happening let's just talk
about the fact that this is a really
great job economy and one of the ways to
get through the baby steps faster is to
increase your income whether that be a
part-time job or making a career pivot i
should also mention that
just today only as we're together from
time to time but today only we're gonna
also talk about uh the strong power move
it is to wear a black t-shirt to work
that's right so we'll also add that
content in as well it's in honor of our
friends the minimalists
we did not talk about this we didn't and
i decided let's go for it i was going to
change because ken wore it first you
know but here we are living our best
life
paul joins us in cleveland paul welcome
to the show
hi there it's great glad glad to talk to
you too you as well how can we help
okay so
i'm 24 i'm ready to move out of mom and
dad's place
i know renting is not a waste of money
but i put myself in a financial
situation where i think i'd be ready to
buy a piece of property my question
would be would there be any downside to
me buying something more less expensive
like a townhome or a condo versus a
single family house
i'm a big fan of doing that move as a
single guy you don't need a
three four bedroom house do you
no i do not
so where are you at financially
are you out of debt do you have an
emergency fund
i have an emergency fund i have zero
dollars in debt
okay so how much emergency fund are we
talking
about 15 000 okay and that's three to
six months of expenses for you yes
plenty and then outside of that how much
have you saved up to buy a house
45 roughly good for you so what's a
condo in your area gonna cost you
a less expensive one less than a hundred
thousand
really
yeah a hundred thousand dollars for a
condo in ohio it might be time to move
ken
i'm not going
um so you're telling me you could put
down 45 today on a condo
yes well that that's also money i'd say
for closing costs i would be less than
that but yes sure man that's incredible
how what's your income
65 okay
so our parameters around this are you
get a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage where
the payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay and if you can you
can obviously going to put down more
than 20 which is going to help you avoid
private mortgage insurance so if you do
it that way there's no downside to
moving today into a condo
now you might have a higher hoa fee so
you factor that into the cost
and my first two homes were townhomes
and i loved it because they take care of
a lot of things that uh normally you
wouldn't get taken care of and so
they're they're gonna take care of the
exterior they're gonna take care of
mowing the lawn and all that kind of
stuff as long as not fenced in so do you
have an opinion george uh for our friend
here uh whether condo or town hall would
be better i feel like townhome might be
a little better
it just depends on what he's looking for
if he's a single guy and he finds a one
or two bedroom and that's all he needs
that's fine it may be cheaper and so as
long as within the parameters buy the
one that that fits your needs that you
love the most but it doesn't sound like
paul over here is going to go buy a 300
000 town home right paul
absolutely not that that's that's crazy
david told me crazy for that how excited
are you to get out of your parents house
uh too excited by
yeah i'll admit that well paul you've
done the hard work now if you called me
and said hey i'm 60 000 in debt i have
no money saved i want to go buy a place
i'd say heck no let's go rent for a year
there's nothing wrong with renting i'm
not mad at renters it's buying patients
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about as a renter so be
prepared make sure you got a line item
in your budget for home maintenance and
repairs because there will be lots of
that and being a homeowner is very
expensive there's property taxes
homeowners insurance is higher than
renters insurance and so as long as you
factor that in which it sounds like you
have this is a great move
okay awesome is that the confidence you
needed
yeah that is just a lot of stuff moving
on and i'm like you know what nice to
get a good opinion every once in a while
and hey listen taking my call take your
time
don't buy the first thing you see i mean
go look at several different condos you
know when you get excited on something
like this and
and you get the green light you know
you can get a little too excited and
shop around and make sure you're working
with a pro you can go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent connect with one of our endorsed
local providers a ramsay trusted agent
and these folks have lots of experience
in your area lots of transactions to
back it up and they can help you sort
through this new endeavor of being a
homeowner man ken this inspires me to
hear a 24 year old who's got a great
head on the shoulders doing it the right
way yeah well you know
he's probably been very very wise even
though he didn't want to live with mom
and dad living with mom and dad for a
while has obviously helped him get to a
place where he can
uh you know buy what he wants to buy and
he wasn't blowing his paychecks he
clearly was saving it being diligent
thanks for the call paul
ed joins us up next in cincinnati ohio
down the road ed welcome to the show
hey thanks george absolutely how can we
help today
so i am in uh baby step two my wife and
i are um
just trying to pay off our debt as fast
we can by the way two paid off cars and
one that will be paid off next month wow
um what do you got three cars
uh
no but we bought my wife's grandfather's
91 ford ranger for 500 so that i could
use it for my side hustle woodworking
that'll do
that's a deal man
yeah and then um
so the question is uh last month we came
up to the uh end of the month and did
not leave
hardly anything in our checking account
and then realized oh shoot the mortgage
is due on the first
and our paychecks don't go into the
second so i'm wondering if there is a
rule of thumb for what to leave in the
checking account is a buffer so that
situations like that don't happen
absolutely
well we always tell people you know to
do a zero-based budget and some people
think oh i guess that means i need zero
dollars in my bank account and of course
you know that's not the case it means
your income minus your expenses equals
zero and so yes i would have a buffer of
a few hundred dollars at least in there
and make that your zero baseline so if
you say hey we're gonna keep three four
hundred bucks obviously your mortgage is
different this is just uh we haven't
planned properly when it comes to the
budget so i wouldn't say this is a
buffer issue it's a budgeting issue
so let's talk about this you've got how
many paychecks a month you get paid
twice a month both of you
yes okay
and is it first and fifteenth kind of
thing
uh yeah mine usually is
on the first and then my wife's comes in
around like the third and then
mine goes in on the 15th and my wife's
goes in on like the 17th or 18th okay
how are you guys currently creating your
budget
uh we use the every dollar premium app
oh awesome well there's a new feature in
there called paycheck planning which is
exactly designed to do to solve this
issue for you so you can go in and mark
all of the expenses and when they're
going to come out and then based on when
your paychecks are coming in it'll show
you when in the month you're going to
run out you can start moving things
around to make sure the money's there
some people like to get a full month
ahead of expenses and that's great when
you can do that right now in baby step 2
it's probably not gonna be easy
yeah how much margin do you guys have at
the end of the month to throw towards
debt
uh
usually we're putting between uh one
thousand and two thousand five hundred
into debt uh it depends on if my wife's
grad school class is being paid that
month or not okay
so you are you were doing a zero-based
budget where your income minus expenses
equals zero it's just the timings are
right
yes okay got it yeah check out that
paycheck planning piece it sounds like
we've got to move some things around and
you can also you know depending on what
your bills are you can contact those
folks and say hey i'm going to change it
online i want my bill to come out on the
15th instead of the first
and so start to map that out sit down
with your wife make it a little budget
date night and start to move these
pieces around so that you have some
peace and confidence when it comes to
when these expenses are coming out so
that we can knock out this debt
very cool thank you my free spirit uh
wife will love the budget date night yes
oh she's gonna be pumped just pour a
nice beverage make it special light a
candle do whatever you got to do man but
it's so worth it when you get on the
same page i was gonna suggest the
bottomless salad at olive garden oh
that's but not while we're getting
paying off debt ken we're not going to
see the inside of a restaurant oh i i
will do that at home sorry i i retract
my statement
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell joined by my colleague
ken coleman
guys have you ever noticed when you
commit to changing one area of your life
it's easier to make progress in other
areas we notice that with debt free
screams all the time here on the stage
and we've met thousands of people on
their journey to building wealth who
accomplished other amazing things along
the way like losing 50 pounds finding
careers they love overcoming stress and
anxiety
and what's interesting is that what
seems impossible becomes possible when
you have a smart plan and when you turn
up the focus and intensity on your goals
and that's why we're bringing our event
smart conference to dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd
smart conference is the one day event
where we help you build momentum in all
areas of your life whether you just lost
your job the credit card bills are
eating up your paychecks or you're
feeling all alone in this crazy world we
got you
ramsey personalities rachel cruz dr john
deloney ken coleman dave ramsey and
myself will be on stage giving you a
smart plan for your money your
relationships personal growth and career
so join us live in person october 22nd
get your passes before they sell out
this is my favorite event we do all year
long go to ramseysolutions.com events to
reserve your seats today
taylor kicks us off right now in kansas
city kansas city we're going there
taylor how's it going
well pretty good man how are you we're
doing great what's going on
so i just started uh
looking at the uh the plans here for uh
the seven baby steps cool and um
yes it is welcome to the club my friend
thank you
um so my question is do i keep paying
the minimum monthly payments on
everything or do i stop
those minimum monthly payments to save
the thousand dollars and then pay off
from smallest to largest
great question we definitely want you to
make those minimum payments and save up
a thousand dollars really quickly we
only get behind on payments we don't
want you to fall in these to go in
collections and create even more of a
mess so how much debt do you have
uh fourteen thousand nine hundred eighty
one dollars
okay let's call it 15k what's your
income uh 16 an hour so right around 32.
what are you doing for work
uh currently working at a plastics
company
plastics okay
and how old are you
29
okay
well i'm going to let ken speak into how
we get this income up because this is
going to speed up the process through
the baby steps we talk about how your
income is your greatest wealth building
tool and we need to increase the shovel
to get through this faster because right
now 15k making 16 an hour it's going to
take you a while to pay off debt isn't
it
yeah that's correct are you working 40
hours a week
uh yes um
right now a little bit more about 50.
okay cool now what kind of debts are we
talking
uh 9 000 on a car
uh
3 000 on credit cards and then just
miscellaneous 100 200 debts here and
there okay and have you been living
paycheck to paycheck and kind of living
on the credit card as your emergency
fund
oh the credit cards were actually back
from when i was in the military and
never got around to paying those off
okay so you're able to pay all of your
bills without going further into debt
right now
correct awesome well that's step number
one we got to stop the bleeding stop
going into debt and just take it off the
table and go we're going to find another
way
so next up you have no money in the bank
currently
uh correct
okay
so the question is how quickly can we
save a thousand dollars the average
person that follows this plan with
gazelle intensity does it in under 30
days and that means side jobs we're
selling stuff we're pausing all
investing we are changing our tax
withholdings if we're getting refunds
we're doing everything we can to find
the proverbial change in the couch
cushions
so based on all that how much money can
how fast will it take to save up that
thousand dollars for you
um
well if i start working you out over
time probably three weeks
three weeks i love it so we're gonna
make minimum payments and all of those
debts for three weeks while we get a
thousand dollars
then all the margin we were using to
create the thousand dollars is going to
be applied to those debts and we're
laying them out smallest to largest
ignoring the interest rate and are
attacking the smallest one with a
vengeance until it's gone and that frees
up a payment doesn't
it uh yes exactly that i'm guessing
towards the next smallest debt with the
extra money you are already saving for
the thousand you're getting this
so ken how can we get our friend uh
taylor his income up well taylor what do
you want to do long term are you already
on that path
uh yes once i get this paid off i wanted
to actually start going to college for
uh
it's a bit of a strange business but
people would pay me to break into their
businesses to make sure no one else can
break into their businesses you mean
like physically
physically electronically anything
allowed in the contract okay interesting
why do you have to go to college for
that
um it looks good
to have degrees and things like that is
what i've been told
uh anybody i'm trying to get a contract
out to not true
no nope
are you if you're if you're talking
about cyber security as one option right
or you know that you're talking about
electronically digitally kind of
creating security for businesses and
then if we're talking like
physical security like they can't break
in this door because we've got this
whatever
the customer that you will get for that
won't care at all if you have a degree
the customer will care about your
credibility only
and and that's the language you use the
ability to go okay here's my assessment
process here's what i do i come in and i
do this this and this electronically or
digitally and that will let me know
where you've got some holes and then i
come over here and it the way that you
explain it you've got a mental a a real
brochure if you will
that you can explain your services
clearly
succinctly
and credibly
then they're going to go man i i feel
like i need that
they don't care if you have a degree
if this is the business that you want to
do this is service based has nothing to
do with the degree at all and listen i'm
trying to save you time and money i'm
not saying it's a bad idea to go to
college i'm saying if that was your
purpose in getting a degree brother i
could save you years
and tens of thousands of dollars
i'd start doing that on the side right
now
okay or working for somebody who does
that right now and that's where you're
gonna get the real life experience
that's going to lead to the credibility
and oh by the way you'll get some
connections
so that's that's that's me addressing
your long-term direction as it relates
to you making more running more money
right now i reported on this on the ken
coleman show two days ago we saw in the
july jobs report we just saw august come
out i haven't had a chance to analyze it
but in the july jobs report there was
one stark piece of data george and it
was that we are seeing more people in
america
than ever before take part-time jobs for
non-economic reasons now what they mean
by that
is they didn't have to take the
part-time job to actually make ends meet
they're doing it maybe to get out of
debt maybe they're doing it to save up
for a wedding or what you know who knows
what and and so in this case taylor
we have got so many part-time jobs that
are available and in making 18 20 22 an
hour doing something that has nothing to
do with your long-term uh professional
direction is okay in this moment because
of what george has just shared with you
and you're brand new to the baby steps
and this increase in income can uh
increase your speed through the baby
steps so i would say let's go get
anything that we can that's paying more
than 16 an hour and that helps as it
relates to your long-term direction save
yourself
time and tens of thousands of dollars by
not pursuing a degree that you don't
need
so it sounds like your heart is not in
plastics and so where can we go make
more than 16 bucks an hour right now to
pay off debt quickly and most people
following this plan awareness at 18 to
24 months a warehouse there you go an
amazon warehouse is going to pay you 20
to 22 an hour and and and they're always
looking for people because they have
high turnover which is okay for you
because you're not going to be there
long term that's one example
so taylor we want to help you out and do
you solid here i'm going to gift you one
year of financial peace university
that's got nine lessons that's going to
change the way you handle money and with
that i'll give you every dollar premium
our budgeting tool to help you make a
plan for every single one of those
dollars coming in i hope that encourages
you along this journey i'm so glad you
found us man this is i love when we have
a new listener who goes i just found you
guys and i'm ready to pay off debt we
need a new listener gift
i like that little welcome basket if you
will yeah
maybe from paycheck to purpose let's
throw that in there awesome there it is
financial peace university every dollar
premium from paycheck to purpose and
that's not all folks thank you george
there you go my kids need shoes but wait
there's more is there more no that's it
for now okay i don't know what else to
give the guy the kid and caboodles right
there all kinds of things total money
makeover let's throw that in there give
it away dave's stuff austin's sycamine
there we go we're pulling for you taylor
call us back when you're debt-free we'd
love to celebrate with you man this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman this hour this is the ramsey
show open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five we are here
to help you take the next step with your
life with your money with your career so
many people are at a crossroads right
now
wondering how they can increase their
income wondering how they can leave a
toxic
boss how to get out of debt oh i can
tell them george we want to help you ken
is here for you in that regard and i'll
help answer those money questions
michael joins us in phoenix michael
welcome to the show
hi um as i said my name is michael
i'm looking to buy my first home but i'm
having some trouble with um the 15-year
versus the 30-year fixed i know you guys
say to put
15-year fixed
i feel comfortable with putting a down
payment but just want some guidance on
how to be able to afford my first home
sure so give us some numbers here what's
your income
so total monthly income
after tax is around nine thousand
dollars a month awesome on average great
currently have separate from my
emergency savings have 80 000 cash set
aside for a purchase
um but when i use the
ramsey calculator it really only tells
me that i can put buy a home for around
317 which in my area
affords you a
dumpster on the side of the road so just
want some ideas on what i can do whether
i should just wait and
or whether i should just buy a different
type of property are you single
i'm single yeah and you're looking at
single-family homes condos town homes
what are we talking
i want a single-family home um
nothing too crazy but uh trying to stay
away from the condo our town home and
why is that
um well i understand that they're harder
to resell um in a scenario where the
market is down so concerns there
george is a townhouse expert
you just told me the phoenix area is
really hot right
yes it is
so you're telling me townhomes just
aren't selling single-family homes
they're the only ones that are selling
i would say they're not selling or they
are selling now but it is an area where
the market does
take a dip but i'm not saying that it is
going to but
even even honestly even town homes are
looking at 350 000 plus
and they just have such high hoa fees
have you looked into what those fees are
yeah i mean you're looking at anywhere
from four to five hundred dollars a
month
i don't buy that you're telling me all
over the phoenix area 500 a quarter yeah
yeah a quarter okay well that changes
the game
so we're talking
125 bucks a month
incorrect that's very reasonable
certainly could be so um
i mean i truthfully i think you have
your site set high there's two options
here i'll lay them out for you're not
stuck
either
we delay the purchase and we save up
more cash so let's say you have 120 down
and you wait another year
then we can maybe get into a single
family home on the low end or we can get
into a town home more quickly with the
money we have and we stay there for
three four years maybe pay that off and
then use all of that towards a single
family home a few years down the line
this is not forever
what's causing the itch michael you know
we gotta wait for what we want sometimes
and uh there's something that's causing
this itch what is it
um i mean i would say lots of colleagues
are buying those second homes
properties so i know chasing what you
want um but i feel like the income is
enough to support it it's just an idea
on how much longer i should wait what if
you looked in a vacuum and you couldn't
see what anyone else around you was
doing
would that change things
i would say so yes boom we just
unfollowed a bunch of people on
instagram and we avoided a lot of water
cooler conversations
yeah you got to choose what's best for
you
and and george is absolutely right let's
just look at this from a uh maybe a
different viewpoint
where do you want your life
to be or what do you want your life to
look like
25 30 years down the line you don't have
to answer that but but you can begin to
visualize that
and when you start to think about the
end the destination
where you ultimately want to be and what
you want life to look like then it's a
lot easier to
uh get past the distractions of while
i'm comparing my now to somebody else's
now when really this isn't about the now
it's about the long-term future am i
right
i would agree yeah i think it's
perspective my man and listen i'm
preaching to the choir here okay
i you know i've always been a guy that
wants you know i want to want to make
progress as fast as absolutely possible
but you know there's their progress is
uh
you know progress is incremental at many
times and then wham after many years of
incremental progress then we we have
this unbelievable payoff and i think i
can hear it in your voice it's a hope
that you're encouraged i'm not picking
on you i hope that you're encouraged
that you've got to be focusing on your
long-term vision and what must be true
for that to happen
thanks so much for the call man remember
this we don't know your friend situation
they could be broke up to their eyeballs
losing sleep there's a good chance they
don't pay check george tell folks uh
what the average car payment in america
733
that means a lot of people
have even higher car payments to get to
that average and your friends that are
buying a second house may be watching
shysters on instagram telling them to
leverage themselves up to their eyeballs
a lot of shysters out there you like
that word that's such a great one it's a
great word to say stay the course man
don't worry run your own race and uh
i've said this before ken i'll probably
butcher it but the problem with running
other people's race is that there is no
finish line
it's never enough no i gotta write that
it's never enough say it again george
the problem with running other people's
race is that there is no finish line and
that's what we see time and time again
comparing your life because back in the
day ken you didn't know what your your
co-workers where they lived and what
their life was like and where they
vacationed and now it's in the palm of
your hand 24 7. and there's a growing
movement a little bit of a pivot uh
george there's a growing pivot uh
all over the internet and in social
media where people want to know what
each other makes and they think this is
great oh we need transparency
let me tell you something
that's going to turn into this big
giant
comparison cesspool and people don't
understand that and the very people that
you think you want to you want to help
by telling them what you make or they're
going to end up resenting you it's
nonsense comparison never ever
ever pays off i'm going to throw a
rachel cruz quote and quote
here we go comparisons are the thief of
joy it's true
i'm taking joy and if that means putting
the comparisons down and doing it my way
even if it's slower even if it means i
don't have a house and they do
right now here you go if you're going to
compare yourself to somebody there's
only one person you should compare
yourself to the you of yesterday oh
there's another tweet we're dropping
some gems we're like socrates over here
well i don't think we are okay fair
point yo
aristotle give me something ken no it's
we're two guys in black t-shirts yeah i
think that's probably that's a fair
point thanks for bringing us back well
both of those things are true but it's a
great point but here's the deal if i'm
going to compare myself to anybody it's
like
yesterday in my personal life my
professional life my financial life my
spiritual life my physical life whatever
that's okay
but looking at everybody else
as the measure
of who i want to be or where i want to
go is just deadly it'll crush your
spirit it will create resentment
and it will ultimately turn into
discouragement
that's why a lot of people fall off the
path whether trying to get out of out of
debt uh trying to lose weight trying to
get in a healthy relationship is as they
start comparing their progress to
everybody else and then when you're
always measuring it and everything's
moving all the time of course you're
going to become frustrated
and then you can only take so much
frustration before you just go ah forget
it well it's one of the reasons we see
broke people driving nicer cars than
millionaires oh yeah we've got this
thing all twisted oh yeah millionaires
are going well why would i put my my all
my money in depreciating asset buying
new cars i'm gonna drive an older car
that gets me from a to b because i don't
care what people think yep
i'm seeing a theme here today ken
not caring what other people think is a
superpower yeah and the sooner we can
get there and add in some common sense
and add in some discipline
then we've got something on our hands
here yeah you know it's interesting you
say that because when you said that it's
like we all fight that as humans you
know why because we want to belong like
humans want to belong to a tribe to a
group we want to feel accepted and so i
think what has to happen is we got to
change the group of people we want to
belong to if we want to belong to
uh to baby steps millionaires of people
that have financial peace let's start
hanging out with those people change you
hang around with that's it that'll help
man good stuff there that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books my
thanks to my stellar co-host ken coleman
all the folks in the booth the bro booth
as we now call them austin is that what
we're calling james zack andrew kyle
they're all in there
affectionately the bro booth yes
fine and david too he's upset with me
now and of course you america we can't
do the show without you we love you guys
appreciate you listening in we'll be
back with you before you know it
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where we help you get
control of your money get ahead in your
career and get on the path to living
well
i'm george campbell joined today by
fellow ramsey personality ken coleman
and we are excited to take your call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five we appreciate you
listening in this afternoon
wherever you're listening
which if you didn't know we are pretty
much everywhere these days you can find
us of course on your local radio station
you can find us on apple podcasts
spotify google amazon music youtube
iheartradio siriusxm and the ramsey
network app so many places i mean
there's something for everyone here ken
really is yeah i mean it's a it's a
buffet a buffet of goodness of hope and
over over 600 radio stations now holding
strong and we just keep expanding as new
platforms come about we want to make
sure that everyone has access we're at
whatever their preferred method of
listening or watching is so thank you to
all of you who are joining us around the
world on all these platforms we
appreciate you
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five naftali joins us in
new york city how you doing naftali
hello how's everything george is this
the naftali that i'm thinking of
that's me oh it's so good to hear from
you my friend naftali is one of uh one
of our amazing business owners that's a
part of entre leadership our business
playbook and i'm excited to take your
call today how can we help you
sure i have a question i'll give you a
drop of background i work in a
not-for-profit organization called hamas
pic
which stands in this translate to
provider and we provide services support
and hope to people going through
challenges so they could lead a
fulfilling productive life
my question for you today is
what comes first
people
or systems we hear so much about how
important it is to have the right people
and we hear so much about how important
it is to have the right system
which one comes first interesting now
where is this question coming from this
is a struggle in your own business
so this is a question i'm going around
with in my head for about two weeks
it's a
philosophical concept that i'm trying to
get to the bottom of it it's a nice
conversation every business owner that i
meet over the last two weeks i'm asking
this question but it's also a technical
question that we have in the business
every time we open a new position or a
new department where you know we're
thinking
should we
invest a little bit take it slowly
build the system and then hire like a
regular guy
following the system or do we bring in
the right person that could build the
system
so on and so forth so
i thank you
i think you've begun to answer your own
question
and and the the issue is is how you
define a system
so i'm curious to know how would you
define systems in the way that you ask
the question how would you define
systems
that's a great question a great thought
so i would find it that we have a clear
standard
that is documented with the proven
process that this is how we do
whatever task or whatever project at
hand right and so i i think that's a
wonderful definition and so my answer is
uh that it is not an either or you
you've i appreciate the question but i
think it's the wrong question
i don't think it is people first or
systems first or systems first or people
first i don't think it's a
a uh a very clear choice like that all
the time i think it is a function of uh
there is a way that you want the
business to run
and that is we teach here at entree
leadership as a part of race we teach
about values that values what you the
leader value
um is what you want to see the company
value and so values determine decisions
we make decisions based on values it's
so
on the systems question it is a function
of uh if we've got to create a new
system
maybe around a new service or a new
product
then you would take that case by case
you go all right
maybe we get a person in here who's got
experience with this and they come in
and we we get going on this new product
offering or service offering and then we
figure out the right system after we get
going but that's a case-by-case basis if
that seems to make any sense to you at
all
it makes a lot of sense of course
everything's case-by-case basis it's not
like it's the chicken in the act
situation what comes first that's right
every time differently but i've heard um
and and i finished reading a great book
on on system and the system is
everything and i'm like it bothered me a
little bit in my stomach because we all
know that people is what's driving
everything and that's correct or even
goes as far as
explaining that of course we need people
because we need somebody to create the
system and i'm like that's why you need
people to create a system we need people
because we love people we treat people
like friends because friends as a
service
so many good things about the people and
the fun environment and the culture we
want to build and serve the community
the people and the clients and all that
so i was like
if there's a right why behind
whatever we decide to do at that
specific case and i think that's what it
comes down to a little bit of my head
and i want to hear what you guys have to
share on it it depends why do you need a
system and the best answer that i got
from
a business owner
drew lancaster is people comes first
because
systems are here to serve the people
because if you have the right people and
you give them the right tools and the
right
system they will that's correct make an
even better job and feel fulfilled and
accomplished and do so much better so
it's always case by case after all
that's right and that's and that's the
point that i'm making is that you know
people are what the leaders number one
responsibility should be focused on is
loving people if we've learned anything
from the 50 plus million people that
have changed jobs over the last year
george is that people want to be loved
and if they don't feel valued they're
going to look somewhere else you know i
just give one further example because
we're coming up on college football
season and nfl football and even if
you're not a football fan you can
certainly understand this analogy if you
look at a great coach like a nick saban
if you hate alabama everybody relax i'm
just using him as an example if there's
someone who has had a long history of
sustained excellence and i've had the
pleasure of interviewing him and if
anybody knows anything about nick saban
he is a system guy he he has the same
thing for lunch every day at the same
time he is a very disciplined and as a
result a disciplined leader he has a
very disciplined program
but he would be the first to tell you
that all of his systems and all of his
disciplined
disciplined processes that he
has employed over the years he'd be the
first to tell you that doesn't win
championships players do
and that's why he put so much effort
into recruiting great talent
and so it is as a as a leader your focus
should be people first but the way that
that question is posed never lock
yourself into oh what do i do create a
system first no it's it's we're going to
make a decision based on
the situation right in front of us so
hopefully that hopefully that gave you
some clarity and some confidence yeah
without that foundation of hiring the
right people who care deeply you know
that's what everyone wants to work with
and we just did an episode on this can
on the entree leadership podcast which i
hope how to use systems to achieve your
goals with craig rochelle he breaks it
down masterfully so go check that out
naftali thank you so much for the call
it's good to hear from you my friend if
you're interested in conversations like
this business and leadership every
single week i'm interviewing the best
leadership minds out there to help
leaders grow themselves their teams
their profits and that is a free podcast
on the ramsey network you can listen to
it watch it on youtube wherever you want
the entree leadership podcast go check
it out more of your calls coming up
right here on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you've heard the news folks we are
technically in a recession the stock
market is falling inflation's out of
control all right
can i just come on george it's an eensy
teensy weensy it's like a restaurant
everybody needs to relax and when it
comes to investing this is no time to
panic stay level-headed don't jump off
the investing roller coaster because of
all the gloom and doom you're hearing
i'm getting dms about this people are
wanting to cash out their 401k they're
scared to jump into the market
don't do this folks
history shows us the economy recovers
time and time again it happened after
the great depression 911 the great
recession in 2008 so this is actually a
great time to invest because when the
market's down it's on sale and who
doesn't love a good deal
i love a good deal george i know you do
you're maxinista ken oh what i've run
into you at t.j.maxx one time
oh my gosh yeah yeah you can't just
throw stuff like that out there that can
hurt a guy's brand it's a deep cut
stacey thank you you were there for her
we were in the home goods section i was
there because i had to can we clear that
up please all right you ran into me a tj
i'm sorry i will recover from that
i don't know how to recover from that
back into this well you back into the
stuff like that okay i apologize there
you go so when it comes to investing you
got to be smart about this and work with
someone who can guide you through it so
if you need help finding an investing
pro check out our smart vester pro our
smart investor program it's an easy way
to find pros who actually serve with
excellence they're going to be there to
help you figure out what's best for you
and stay focused on your long-term goals
you can get connected with up to five
smartvestor pros in your area at
ramseysolutions.com
smart vester you can talk with these
pros interview them pick the one that
you want to work with and make an
investing plan that you feel confident
about again that's ramsay solutions.com
smart vester
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell he's ken coleman and we are
here to help you with life money career
whatever you're going through we'd love
to help you take the right next step
jordan joins us up next in dc
jordan welcome to the show
uh yes hello hello can you hear me yes
we can hear you jordan what's up
hi thanks for taking my call um my
question was how would i be able to pay
for debt
well pay off that while cash flow in
college
how much is college uh
4 300 a semester
how much debt do you have
all together 24 000.
what kind of debt is it
sixteen thousand student loans and seven
thousand on the car
all right what's your income
31 000 after taxes that's your take-home
pay
correct and are you gonna continue
working while you go to college
yes at the same
same amount of hours
yeah i'm not young part-time it's an
internship
okay that's a 31k
yes okay so you're asking how do i pay
off debt while in college the goal right
now do you need to go to college what's
the purpose behind this
um so i do have to go to college because
it's part of the internship
um
right now like my internship is
helping me get real real world
experience
and yeah i do have to go to college for
that and i'm finishing three semesters
so
trying to get it done how many hours do
you have with your current rhythm of
life
that you could give to working more to
make more money
so every weekend i'm free so saturday
sunday i have nothing to do well
there's the short answer george can help
you with the debt snowball but i'm going
to tell you right now is the guy who
focuses on work i'd be working my fanny
off on those weekends because you're a
young guy you got you should have no
life other than working like crazy uh
because you can earn a really good chunk
of change
uh over a weekend i mean just to give
you an idea george and i i'm no i've
i've been out of college a long time i
know you're shocked by that admission
all right uh but even back in the day i
was doing room service at a hilton hotel
on the weekends it was clearing hundreds
of dollars in tips back in the day i
wish i could open the door and see ken
coleman no it was not her
room service and i had the tray right
there man it would make good money so so
i mean that's one thing right now we we
want to work our tail off and make more
money because what that's going to allow
us to do is put more money towards the
debt snowball absolutely so jordan i
think you can do both of these your a1
is cash flowing college because we are
not going to touch debt
and so if that means hey to cash flow
this next semester i'm gonna have to
pause the debt snowball and make minimum
payments i'm okay with that
how many more semesters do you have left
uh three that's it and another thing
with the um so with the weekends i was
planning on using all those for studying
because i had five hard classes so that
was kind of why i was holding off on
working extra but
how much money do you have in the bank
right now
uh 1 000 towards it's going towards
college okay well let me let me address
that so
i i hear you on that and i can't
question you if you got to use that time
to study i mean if that's legit
and you have to use most of your weekend
to study to finish
well then maybe it's not realistic for
you to pay off much debt while you're
finishing school and that may be okay
george he doesn't have that much time
left i just want to clarify my advice on
that but i mean if you're not studying
every waking hour there's got to be
something you can do and we found that
while folks are in school you know
working 15 to 20 hours a week actually
increases the gpa
because you've got to be real
disciplined yeah you've got a full
schedule dialed in we're not hanging out
dilly dallying so i'm looking at the
numbers here you got three semesters 4
300 a piece that's 12 800 right
yes so the question is how quickly can
we cash flow that 12 800 and once we
know that schools paid for now we can
use any extra money to start attacking
debt and if that happens after we're
done with these semesters i'm okay with
that
okay
so you can do both of these things and
hopefully once you're out of uh out of
college how much you're gonna be making
uh i'm a computer science major so i'm
kind of hoping for 70 plus right yeah so
now think about you're out of college
you're making 70k school's done and now
we just need to attack this 24.
that's a doable situation
um do you have financial peace have you
gone through it
i have not okay that's gonna be my gift
to you as you finish out this college
experience so hang on the line austin's
gonna pick up we're gonna gift you one
year financial peace university and i
think that will keep you motivated along
the way don't take your foot off the gas
and i know you've got a lot going on
you're juggling a lot right now but
we're going to get you debt-free in no
time so hang on the line austin will
gift you one year financial peace
university watch all the lessons use the
every dollar budget and be very diligent
while you're in college so that you can
step out into that career with some
freedom on your hands we're pulling for
you man phillip joins us up next in
atlanta phillip welcome to the show
hey how's it going great what's going on
with you
um so i'm 19 years old and uh i plan on
getting engaged soon wow and so i uh i
plan on buying an engagement ring and a
wedding band
and um
the one i'm looking at is about 3 500
and i could
pay for it in cash but
i've only had a credit card for about
three months
and
i really want to build credit
so i was thinking
i mean i've been paying on my credit
card every month not charging over uh
40
and uh i was wondering if it would be
wise to get
a personal loan through my bank no and
pay on that to build credit no no
we're wrong on all accounts here phillip
if you have if you've been listening to
the show for any amount of time you know
that we'd never tell you to go into debt
and so if you're going to do this we're
going to cash flow everything how long
you been with this girl
uh about two years almost three okay
when do you oh i gotta know really quick
when are you gonna pop the question
um
i was thinking if i could get the ring
i would do it maybe this december yeah
all right okay phillip number one you
got the cash cut up the cards we don't
need that
and if you need more information on that
check out my podcast the fine print we
do a whole episode on the dirty truth
behind your credit score and you're a
young guy and this is how it starts man
it starts with it's like the gateway
drug to debt you don't need a credit
score because we're not going to go into
debt and when it comes to a house to get
a mortgage you can do manual
underwriting without a score way later
down the road when that time comes we're
gonna cash flow the ring cut up the
credit card you don't need to worry
about your stupid credit score and live
your life debt-free if you start off
your marriage debt-free and stay that
way
man
that is a peaceful way to live and we
know that money fights money problems
one of the leading causes of divorce in
america today so take your time do this
with wisdom don't take out the loan and
maybe looking at getting a cheaper ring
that's my advice for you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by ken coleman
this is the ramsay show
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com their 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color as ken and i
tend to do they will remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best deal
today's question comes from jesse in
iowa i absolutely hate my job
i'm married with four children
completely debt-free including our house
and have plenty of savings but i'm not
passionate about my job and it's not
something i ever wanted to do it's a
career that i was offered by a family
member and i've been in it for 10 years
and have hated it every day i want to
take some time off to explore other
options would it be irresponsible for me
to quit my job and not start another job
right away we will lose half our
household income but we will get along
just fine with only my wife's salary
yeah i'd quit tomorrow
in this scenario
this is one of the rare scenarios by
which i'd say yeah walk today walk to
and it's the power following the baby
steps it is they have zero debt huge
amount of savings and he's not even
going to touch the savings because he
said they're just fine on his wife's
salary and i think in a situation like
this where you heard the word hate at
least two times in this question um it's
time for him to walk away and get some
real clarity and i think that a guy like
him who's very disciplined he and his
wife clearly to get to this financial
peace status he's going to find
something pretty quickly and get pretty
excited about the past so in this case
abso freaking lutely take the time off
but explore
and and take your time
i'm not worried about him sitting at
home a year from now i'm just not
because when he's that kind of burnt out
on this career he's gonna be like oh my
gosh i feel free for the first time yeah
and i would also tell you that just from
experience i know that he has some
pretty clear ideas about what he's
interested in and i think he's the time
off is gonna allow him to to do what i
call clarify and verify and that just if
you're kind of listening you're new to
this uh this type of content for me here
at ramsey solutions uh clarifying is is
like doing the good old-fashioned
research project uh learning everything
you can the highs the lows the good the
bad the ugly from people who are
actually doing the thing that you think
you're interested in that's clarify
and and when you do that your brain is
gathering information
and then your heart is considering the
information and that's the verifying if
your heart's going
and what then this is a common scenario
for people to just sit in a job they
hate for a decade very common what's
behind that are they just kind of
paralyzed by the unknown yes and what
it's going to take to nail the new uh
well yes and the reason is is because we
as humans
um our natural tendency is to
accept being miserable
as opposed to
stepping into the uncomfortable
we just what we because the miserable we
know it
yeah i know i gotta go deal with the
jerk you know that sits next to me all
day long you know he does nothing i'm
busting my hump he's over there playing
words with friends you know what i mean
whatever the situation is you don't like
your leader right or in this case you
don't like to work at all and there's
zero passion and it's just a j-o-b and
you're bored out of your mind and your
spirit has slipped out of your body a
long time ago well we would ex we were
just more comfortable accepting that
because we go i know what to expect and
i can grin and bear it if you will to
use the old phrase
the uncomfortable is is attached to the
unknown
and so that's really scary so we'll put
up with something as opposed to going
all right let me go dig
and go get answers to the things that
i'm not sure about and in doing so i
haven't committed i haven't left i could
still be miserable while i go get some
answers but that that's really why uh
fear and doubt and i also believe it'll
and you just nailed it so that's the
fear part the doubt is i doubt that i
can actually find something that i love
who's gonna want to hire me when i
haven't been doing this job but it's a
new thing yeah i'm afraid that i might
fail or i doubt that i can actually find
it that those are the common voices well
it takes me back to the old proverb but
the best time to plant the tree was 10
years ago the next best time today get
after it start today best time to quit
that job was 10 years ago the next best
time today and that's what you can do
when you're at baby step seven no
payments in the world thanks for the
question
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five mike joins us in
scranton pennsylvania mike welcome to
the show
hi ken hi george thanks for having me
how are you guys today doing great
what's going on
okay so i work for my uncle at a family
business where we engrave and install
tombstones and
my plan and his plan is for me to buy
the shop off of him when he retires in
10 to 15 years
i was looking for guidance as far as
what college courses should i be taking
in order to prepare me more for the
administrative side of running a
business uh there's actually like
there's no
degree required to do what i do but the
administrative side is uh
so why do you think college is the only
path to do that
um
well
additionally i'm in the army reserve so
i have access to
uh military to uh military
aid for college and
at the rank i'm at in the reserve uh
college credits give us promotion points
which makes it easier for us to promote
to promote faster so
would it be free then for you to go take
these courses
um not free but it would cover a
substantial amount if i was to go
part-time and start taking courses would
it would it also apply the military
discount or credit that you're referring
to would also apply to certifications
some non-traditional college courses but
still education
um that's something i would have to look
into i'd look into it um
because
i i'm curious to know what specific
administrative skills you feel like you
need to either acquire or sharpen
um so when my uncle took over the
business he
had to hire somebody and continues to
employ somebody
to do all books accounting all that
stuff because it was something he never
knew and that's uh
something while i will still likely hire
somebody to do it i don't want them
taking a week off work to
prevent that work from being done well
but that's a but that okay appreciate
the thought but that's not going to
happen just because you hire someone to
do accounting work and they take a week
off it doesn't mean that they're you
know somebody there there's going to be
somebody where their discipline
multi-disciplined issues or whatever and
and they can keep doing basic accounting
while that person's on vacation because
here's the real question as you see
yourself eventually stepping into the
ceo role
what do you want to spend most of your
time on as ceo
i asked you what do you want to what do
you want to be spending your time your
days
doing most of
probably very similar to what my uncle
does he runs he does all the design work
in the sales
great so you don't need to go get
administrative courses and skills for
something that a you don't want to do
it's not even best for the company
anyway
and you can hire people to do that and
you can come up with systems to where
when they're on vacation it's going to
be okay bills will still be paid like
really sharp accounting people the right
people and you get the right systems in
there everything's going to keep running
smoothly even when they're on vacation
okay
i did this comes down to opportunity
cost
right
do you understand what i mean when i say
that
yeah i mean you spending time and money
your two most precious resources
to uh acquire a skill that you really
honestly don't even need
and you can learn the basics of
accounting right now because you're
working for your uncle go hey unc do you
mind if i spend a little bit of time you
know hanging out with our accountant and
just learning how they do it just so i
understand the ins and outs of the
business that doesn't require any
college course that's just you being
diligent and being
intentional
okay yeah i think you spending time
getting mentored right now in the
business is going to be more beneficial
than a theory that you learned in a
college class
now i will tell you we have entree
leadership which is our business
playbook and we have a whole team over
there that
unpacks how dave has built this thing
from a card table in his living room to
now this massive company and what i want
to do for you mike is gift you three
months of entre leadership elite this is
basically our online membership there's
courses in there more importantly
there's this thing called advisory
groups yes with one of our business
coaches and
business folks like you
leaders who want to grow and they're
learning from each other so i'm going to
give you a three month free trial i got
that cleared by our team to do that for
you
generally it's just a one month free
trial so dig into that join an advisory
group watch the courses take advantage
of those resources and i think that will
give you the confidence to step into
this new role way more than any college
environment could do so thanks so much
for the calm i appreciate it uh we love
small business they are the backbone of
this economy and we love helping leaders
like you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
do
[Music]
our scripture of the day deuteronomy 31
6
be strong and courageous do not fear or
be in dread of them for it is the lord
your god who goes with you he will not
leave you or forsake you
frank sinatra once said the big lesson
in life baby is never be scared of
anyone or anything
there you go ken sinatra for you i feel
like if you're gonna read a sinatra
quote that's got baby in it you gotta
try to take his voice on give me that i
feel like i think you should defensive
to all people groups if i tried a
sinatra compression the big lesson in
life baby is never be scared of anyone
or anything that was pretty good not bad
i picture him with the uh bow tie done
he's got a cocktail martini in his hand
good enough for government work ken yeah
nice nice impression thank you james is
thrilled with that that's uh it'll be in
show notes afterwards you occurred to me
that we'll be heading to the principal's
office for that one i've only heard him
sing i don't know what his voice sounds
like so i've already done a few
interviews that wasn't bad
i'm not going to give it a good
impression and i certainly wasn't great
but it was serviceable
that's exactly the commentary you want
it was serviceable well i'm trying to
keep it real i don't you know it might
have been bad well let's listen to
christina who's in washington that's
what we can do all right christina how
you doing
good how are you thanks very good
so my husband and i are in steps six and
seven and we're planning on moving in a
couple of years
but our house
needs well it could use some updating
and so i guess our question is
should we continue to decrease the
mortgage with the extra money that we
have every month or start
making some minor and major updates to
the house to potentially increase
the value that way and the
you know make it more marketable
okay so your baby steps six seven we've
got a paid for house at that point and
we're building wealth and gains oh okay
so you're you're squarely in six what's
left on the mortgage
uh we got about 515 on our mortgage
515 000 left
correct yeah um
what's your income so
uh our growth is 280 000. awesome and uh
tell us again you said did i hear you
say you're planning to move and sell
this house in a couple of years
[Music]
correct our kids are all out of high
school by then we don't really like the
county that we're in so we'd like to
move at that point so why not just move
the kids down kids so it's all for the
so how many years are we talking high
school
just two years okay they just they don't
want to switch schools and what are the
renovations going to cost
um
we're thinking about 40 000 we have two
bathrooms and that would be the major
well the bathroom shouldn't cost that
much so i was going to ask you these
days it might everything is crazy
expensive right now yeah but but when
you say major renovations are you
talking about the master bath is one of
those
master bath is one but to be honest
we're in an old colonial from the 80s so
our master bath is like
you know not that master compared to
what houses are these babies here we go
what's the house worth
uh we think about 750 800 000. okay and
if you put this 40k in there do you
think it would then sell for 790 to 830
we do and we think that it would make it
more marketable the area that we're in
has a lot of high-end builders um and
they're putting in a lot of 500 000
square feet plus houses um
so just the area is changing and we're
just we want to make sure that we have
you know buyers
i mean i would do your homework i i've
uh my father-in-law is a custom home
builder and does a lot of reno's and so
i learn a lot from him and i've done
some reading too
and you can do this on your own but you
know you look at kitchens
and you look at like a master bathroom
those are those are two areas that you
can get real value from also backyards i
saw something recently where doing stuff
with your backyard and outdoor living
that can certainly add a lot of value so
i would just do your homework you know
what are some of the minor changes
versus the majors and i would really
only focus on the majors because you're
just trying to make this thing more
marketable so for instance you got an
old colonial home what could you do to
make that master bathroom actually a
master bathroom i think that would
certainly add some value so i think if
you just do your homework there uh
george is that where you're leaning
because they're not going to pay the
house off even with their aggressive
payments by the time that they sell and
move anyway i'm leaning towards doing
what the necessary renovations are
necessary repairs and as you go to list
it you're working with a pro and let the
pro help you go all right if you want to
sell this for this asking price here's
what we're going to need to do and
here's the value that's good so i might
pause on that and just do what's
necessary right now uh and i want it to
be livable it doesn't sound like you
guys are miserable over there sounds
like a cool property no
okay yeah we have about four acres it's
pretty cool where where i gotta ask are
you you're not in dc
so you're in oh we're the suburbs yeah
we're actually suburbs in maryland
how much money do you guys have in cash
outside of the emergency fund
uh we have about
70 000
outside of cash we are we drive
20 year old cars that we're getting
ready to replace um because we keep
breaking down
and we have never taken a honeymoon so
we're going whoa so we have
we have some money
i would upgrade the cars and go on the
honeymoon before making these
renovations i agree with george
you got two years and george is right
when you get closer to selling the house
i'd have a one of our real estate pros
give you some good advice on what
changes to make but right now yeah
replace the cars and go on a honeymoon
for heaven's sakes
yeah i think you can do both of these
things and we'll just put them in order
so let's upgrade the cars let's go on
the honeymoon let's start to make some
renovations that would make it uh really
pop for now for us to enjoy and then
begin start to knock off some of that
mortgage so that you can build more
equity and you're gonna only gain that
back when you go and sell it and so you
should have you know if you're at 515
you sell the thing for 850 you're gonna
have a good 300 in uh
net profits out of that
yes and then hopefully we can just get a
house for cash which is our goal that
would be amazing now you will probably
need to downsize in house at that point
right
yes
moving to a different area that's more
affordable
yeah exactly awesome well thanks so much
for the call christina appreciate it
that's exciting tai will close us out
here in santa ana california ty let's
get right to the question
hey what's up gang hey how you doing
good good hey so
um i know we're short on time i'm just
gonna get right to it uh that's what
they told me so
i um
i uh
i need to know if
i should sell my business
or sell my houses to pay off my debt how
much debt
i got 1.2 million in debt
is that all business debt
no it's uh two houses one in hawaii one
in
california and then um about 200 000 and
whatever you know the basic
everything else i would sell the houses
before the business unless you're trying
to get rid of the business anyways
what's the bit what could the business
sell for the business i had two i had
two
companies reach out to me that want to
buy the business
so if i sell the business then i
wouldn't have to sell the houses and
you're okay selling the business
not really i um yeah i was going to say
one of like
i mean do you do you own your job here
in this business what would you do if
you sold it
well the business is in hawaii and i
live in california and there's no hassle
there for you to run it from california
well there's two there's two options so
one company wants me to
one company wants me to
um
sell in the business
and move back to hawaii
and then the other company wants me
wants to buy the business and have me
stay out here in california or i can
just sell the houses
pay off all the debt
what's your heart telling you today
which one gets you the most excited
i don't know i'm just torn i i don't
know do you want to move to hawaii
a year ago
i was born and raised in hawaii you know
we just got out here to california
so do you want to go back
i i don't know yes you do ty i gotta
tell you we're short on time but i think
you are leaning one way so why don't you
just tell us which way you were leaning
when you called to get our advice
because i know you were leaning one way
what was it
i think we i think i i think i
so both both companies want me to work
for them after the sale
and i think i do better in hawaii that's
where i'm from all right
i would do that
there it is appreciate the call time
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to my co-host ken
coleman all the folks in the booth
keeping the show afloat and you america
we appreciate listening in until next
time spend wisely
save intentionally and give generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you